[S01] 你试着想象一下这个场景啊：那是 1997 年，在《网络创世纪》——呃，就是一款非常古老的网络游戏——的开发过程中，程序员在代码里意外打碎了一块承载着整个虚拟世界的魔法水晶。
[S02] 对，这其实是个很有名的极客圈子里的轶事了。
[S01] 是的。为了让游戏能容纳众多玩家呢，他们被迫将这块水晶的碎片分散到了不同的服务器上，每一个碎片就运行着这个虚拟世界的一个独立部分。
[S02] 他们当时大概完全没有意识到，这个有点儿呃、有点儿被迫为之的极客举动，几乎构成了今天所有千万级并发应用能够存活的基石。
[S01] 没错。所以在我们今天的这项深度探讨任务里，我们就要来拆解一下这本分布式系统领域的圣经《设计数据密集型应用》，也就是大家常说的 DDIA 的第七章：分片。我们要弄清楚，当几亿人同时刷新时间线的时候，数据底层到底发生了什么。好的，让我们来拆解一下。
[S02] 嗯，支撑现代互联网不垮掉的核心机制，确实充满了这种——怎么说呢——在极限压力下逼出来的工程美学。资料里提到了一句非常经典的话，是计算机先驱格雷斯·霍普在一九六二年说的。她说：我们必须跳出顺序 computer 指令的窠臼，我们必须叙述关系，而不是过程。
[S01] 一九六二年？哇，那时候连互联网的影子都还没有吧。
[S02] 对对对。半个多世纪前，她其实就已经预见到了单点计算的物理极限。而所谓的分片，也就是 Sharding，本质上就是我们为了突破这种物理极限，对数据关系进行了一次非常暴力、但又极其精密的重构。
[S01] 呃，提到物理极限，我得在这里抛出一个可能很多人都有的疑问：现在的硬件发展那简直是怪物级别的。比如你在 AWS 或者阿里云上随手就能拉起一台有几 TB 内存、上百个核心的超级服务器，它的吞吐量已经恐怖到了极点。
[S02] 确实，单机性能现在非常强悍。
[S01] 对吧？就像是你的行李太重了，你完全可以花大价钱去买一个特制的超级大背包，这就是垂直扩展。那为什么，为什么非要雇十个人把东西分摊装进十个小背包里，也就是水平扩展？分布式系统意味着我们要去处理那种让人抓狂的网络延迟啊、节点宕机啊。引入分片这种重型武器，它带来的复杂度和收益真的成正比吗？
[S02] 这个是一个非常核心的质疑。纯粹从算力峰值角度来看呢，很多中型应用其实靠一台现代的大型云服务器真的就能跑满全场了。但这里最引人入胜的是：分片的动机早就超越了单纯的性能或者容量。
[S01] 哦，不单单是为了性能。
[S02] 对。当我们把目光转向现在极其普遍的 SaaS 架构，也就是多租户场景的时候，分片提供了一种单机永远无法实现的东西，那就是硬隔离。
[S01] 硬隔离？呃，你的意思是防范那些在系统里过度消耗资源的客户？
[S02] 没错，可以这么理解。你想象一下，假设你运营这一个企业协作平台，后台就是一张巨大的单体数据库表。你的客户里面呢，既有只有十几个人的初创团队，也有那种几万名员工的跨国巨头。
[S01] 嗯，体量超级极大。
[S02] 对。那如果这家跨国巨头在周一早晨突然跑了一个极其复杂的全局数据报表——
[S01] 这个查询可能会瞬间吃掉数据库百分之九十的 CPU 和内存。哇，那就惨了。那个十几个人的初创团队可能连发一条简单的文字消息都会一直转圈圈，直接超时报错了。
[S02] 没错。在单体架构下，所有的租户共享同一个资源池，这就是典型的吵闹的邻居效应。
[S01] 原来如此。所以如果我们将数据进行分片，就可以把这种超级大客户单独隔离开来，甚至就是在物理层面上直接分配专属的服务器集群给这些特定分片。
[S02] 是的。大客户的报表怎么折腾，也只会压榨他们自己所在分片的算力；初创团队在另一个分片里依然可以享受毫秒级的丝滑体验。而且更进一步说，这还涉及到系统的容灾和合规性。
[S01] 合规性这个怎么讲？
[S02] 资料里提到了基于单元的架构：你可以把某些分片的数据完全封装在一个独立的物理可用区里。如果某个机房的光缆突然被挖断了，只有分配到那个机房的租户会受影响。
[S01] 也就是所谓的缩小爆炸半径，对吧？
[S02] 对。另外像 GDPR 这种极其严格的隐私法规，它要求你必须能够彻底物理销毁特定用户的数据。如果你所有客户的数据都纠缠在一块连续的磁盘扇区里，彻底清理简直是噩梦。
[S01] 呃，但如果是基于分片的话，就可以直接把那个对应的存储卷下线或者拆除，干脆利落。
[S02] 完全正确。所以你下一次在用企业邮箱或者各种 SaaS 工具的时候，其实底层都在用这些分片隔离机制来保护你的数据。
[S01] 既然分片能带来资源隔离、容灾控制，还能提升吞吐量，那摆在我们面前的第一个工程难题就是：这蛋糕到底怎么切？按照什么规则来分，才能保证极其公平，不至于产生那种焊的焊死、烙的烙死的偏斜现象呢？
[S02] 最符合人类直觉的切法呢，叫做按范围分片。这就好比一本传统的纸质百科全书。
[S01] 呃，就像第一卷是首字母 A 到 B，第二卷是 C 到 D，这样。
[S02] 对对对。在数据库里，如果主键是用户名，系统可以非常轻松地把字母表切分成几个段落，然后分配给不同的节点。对于范围查询来说，这种切法绝对是天然友好的。
[S01] 嗯。如果我想找名字从 A 到 C 的所有用户信息，系统直接去前面两个分片顺着磁盘扫一遍就全带回来了。但是等等，我发现一个漏洞：如果这是一张 sensor 网络的数据表呢？大家的主键不是名字，而是时间戳。
[S02] 哎，你抓到重点了。
[S01] 对吧？那所有今天产生的新数据，它们的时间戳全都是今天的日期。这就意味着代表昨天、前天的那些分片服务器现在全都在喝茶摸鱼，而所有新来的写入请求全挤在代表今天的那一卷里。那个节点岂不是要被挤爆了？
[S02] 非常敏锐。这就是按范围分片最致命的弱点：热点问题。连续的高并发写入一旦集中，几百台机器的集群瞬间就退化成了单机系统。
[S01] 所以为了打破这种时间的连续性，架构师们引入了哈希分片。
[S02] 哦，哈希分片就是用数学的方法把规律的数据打散。
[S01] 没错。我们不再直接用时间戳，而是把时间戳喂给一个像 MD5 或者 murmur3 这样的哈希函数。哈希函数有个神奇的雪崩效应：哪怕输入只差了一点点，比如十二点零一分和十二点零二分，输出的哈希值也会在整个数字空间里发生天翻地覆的随机跳跃。
[S02] 哇。所以十二点零一分的数据去了节点 A，一秒钟后的数据可能直接飞到了节点 Z。原本潮水一样涌来的数据就被均匀地轰炸到了集群的每一个角落，大家终于都不摸鱼了。
[S01] 是的，写入压力完美打散。但是如果我们将这一点与更大的图景联系起来看，架构设计永远是在做权衡。哈希分片亲手扼杀了一个功能，那就是我们刚才说的范围查询。
[S02] 哎对哦。因为数据完全乱序了。如果我现在要查今天下午一点到二点间的所有数据，根本不知道去哪个节点找。没错，系统别无选择，只能向整个集群所有的节点同时发送请求，这就变成了极其低效的 scatter-gather 操作。但这还不是最极端的，因为这里才是真正有趣的地方：即便有了哈希，人类社会的极端行为依然会打破系统的平衡。
[S01] 贾斯丁·比伯引发的服务器风暴。
[S02] 对，资料里这个案例非常经典。在社交网络里，像比伯这种拥有几百万甚至几千万粉丝的超级节点，他随便发一句早安，几分钟内就是上百万次点赞。
[S01] 这个时候哈希也救不了命了。因为这几百万个请求操作的都是同一个帖子 ID，无论怎么算哈希，结果都指向同一台服务器。
[S02] 没错。听说在某些平台上，这种单一账号的极端热点曾经一度吞噬了整个集群百分之三的算力。这就是极端倾斜。
[S01] 那系统工程师怎么反击呢？面对比伯这种超级热点。
[S02] 应用层的巧妙解法是加盐，或者叫键拼接。既然底层认死理，同样的键只能去同一个节点，那我们就在应用层，在这个帖子 ID 前后人为地加上两位的随机数，比如从零零到九九。
[S01] 呃，这就像是为比伯的粉丝特设了一百个不同的结账通道来分流人群。粉丝的点赞被随机分配到了这一百个新造出来的键上。
[S02] 对，这就把压力均匀分摊到了一百台机器上。
[S01] 但、但是等等。结账是快了，那如果前端页面现在需要实时显示比伯这条帖子的总点赞数，我们要怎么读数据？
[S02] 哎，这就必须要付出代价了。读取的时候，系统就必须向这一百个子键分别发送请求，然后把拿到的一百个结果合并起来。
[S01] 为了拯救一台快要被写爆的服务器，我们硬生生增加了系统的读放大成本。所以这种特殊待遇通常只能留给极少数的超级大 V。
[S02] 是的。那随着数据继续增长，不可避免地我们需要加 server。这就引出了一个非常核心的问题：怎么把旧数据平滑地搬到新机器上，也就是再平衡机制。
[S01] 这个问题我以前想过。最直接的做法难道不是把哈希值除以节点总数然后取余数吗？比如十二除以十余二，就放二号节点。
[S02] 这是一个极其反直觉的陷阱。单次计算没问题，但如果你加了一台机器，节点总数从十变成了十一，除数变了——
[S01] 啊天呐。十二除以十一的余数变成了一。那也就是所有数据的余数全变了，几乎全网的数据都要大搬家。
[S02] 没错。整个网络带宽瞬间被榨干，系统直接瘫痪。所以更好的策略是固定数量的分片。
[S01] 固定数量，就是虚拟的分片吗？
[S02] 对。假设我们一上来就划定一千个固定分片。如果有十台机器，每台就托管一百个分片。当第十一台机器加入时，它只需要向老机器要几个完整的分片过来就行了，完全不用拆开重新算哈希。
[S01] 原来如此。搬家就变成了搬箱子，而不是把箱子里的东西全倒出来重新分。那既然现在的云服务这么发达，系统自动侦测负载，然后全自动驾驶自己移动这些箱子，岂不是最完美的呢？
[S02] 嗯，这就引出了一个非常重要、也是极其严肃的问题：完全的自动化有时候反而会带来无法预测的灾难，也就是所谓的级联故障。
[S01] 级联故障怎么发生的？
[S02] 在分布式系统里，你其实很难判定一个节点是不是真的死了。可能某个节点只是因为刚好在处理一个复杂的查询，响应慢了半拍。
[S01] 但是其他节点误以为它挂了。
[S02] 对。其他节点一想：哎呀它死了，赶紧把它的负载接管过来。结果大量的请求瞬间涌向其他节点，把原本正常的节点也压垮了。
[S01] 然后接着又压垮下一批节点，像多米诺骨牌一样雪崩了。
[S02] 完全正确。所以对于移动分片这种沉重的操作，适度的人工干预，也就是保留一个确认按钮，往往是防止系统全军覆没的安全阀。
[S01] 宁愿让它稍微笨一点。那在日常运行的时候，客户端是怎么在茫茫大海里找到正确的 IP 地址的呢？
[S02] 这就要靠 ZooKeeper 这样的协调服务，或者是像 Cassandra 里用到的流言协议，也就是 Gossip。
[S01] 流言协议？听起来像是在办公室里传播八卦。
[S02] 这个比喻非常贴切。就是每个节点随机挑几个其他节点，互相交换自己所知道的集群状态。一传十，十传百，几秒钟内全网就都知道哪个分片在哪台机器上了。
[S01] 哇。没有中央指挥，全靠大家私下八卦来达成共识，这太奇妙了。不过到目前为止，我们全都在讨论按照主键，比如 ID 来找数据。但是如果我们不用 ID 找呢？
[S02] 你说二级索引？
[S01] 对啊。假设你正在使用一个二手车网站，汽车数据已经按照车辆 ID 分片了，但现在你想找一辆红色的车——这是二级索引。这时候我们要去哪儿找？整个系统完全不知道这辆车在哪儿啊。
[S02] 寻找二手红汽车的难题，这是分片里的硬骨头。架构师只能在两种策略里选一种。第一种是本地二级索引，也叫 scatter-gather 模式。
[S01] 也就是每个分片只管自己的一亩三分地。
[S02] 对。所以为了找红车，系统必须去敲开每一个分片的大门，问：你这里有红车吗？然后把结果收集起来。
[S01] 写入的时候虽然简单，但查询不仅慢，而且容易产生长尾延迟吧？只要有一个节点慢了，我整个查询就得等着它。
[S02] 没错。所以有了第二种选择：全局二级索引。建立一个全局的索引，把红色统统归到某一个特定的分片上。
[S01] 这样读取的时候只要查这一个分片就行了。但是呃，代价是每次有卖家上架一辆新的红色汽车，后台可能就要跨越多个分片去更新索引。
[S02] 完全正确。而且为了保证数据不错乱，系统可能需要动用非常复杂的分布式事务。所以你看，这就是分片的本质：没有完美的方案，永远是在权衡。
[S01] 那么这一切到底意味着什么呢？我们回顾一下：分片，它绝对不是什么魔法，而是一套极致的拆解和协调的艺术。从按范围到哈希，从应对比伯这样的热点，到二手红车的二级索引，本质上我们都是在可伸缩性、查询效率和系统复杂性这个不可能三角里寻找平衡。
[S02] 是的。也给我留下了最后一个非常挑衅性的思考：你看，我们将庞大的数据系统切割成分片，用像 ZooKeeper 或者流言协议来协调，在热点出现时打散重组，甚至还需要加入人工干预的规则来防止雪崩。既然机器系统都需要通过如此精妙的规则来分权制衡和再平衡——
[S01] 嗯哼。
[S02] 那对于我们人类社会日益膨胀的超大型公司组织，甚至未来的去中心化社会结构，这难道不是一种极其相似的生存法则吗？
[S01] 如果一个社会系统大到单点无法承受，我们该如何设计它的「社会学哈希函数」呢？这真的是一个非常深刻的问题。那今天非常感谢大家的收听。下一次你在电商网站选上商品，或者在社交媒体上刷新热搜的时候，希望你能想起这些在后台默默运转的分片魔法。保持你的好奇心，我们下次再见。